what is the purpose of a scene the
purpose of a scene is to advance the
story forward uh one of the notes that I
keep given writers is why do we need
this scene if it's not moving your story
forward sometimes you reveal character
and that helps you know to move the
story forward because we're learning
something about their character but that
should be the purpose of every Scene It
should move things across so for
example a type of scene I always tell
writers to cut is flashbacks that don't
really Advance the story you're you're
just revealing little tidbits but if it
doesn't Advance the present of the story
you don't need the flashback you could
just tell me the story you know so every
scene should serve a purpose and another
way to work around that a little bit is
to sort of layer scenes or merge scenes
a lot of writers tend to write different
scenes to show different things about
characters but I like to layer them to
make them richer and and Advance the
story in a better way so for
example uh if you have a character
that's being teased at school and then
you have another scene where that
character falls in the hallway and I
don't know all of the pain falls on him
but nobody sees him then we're not
connecting the two it would be much
better if in the same classroom scene
when everyone is teasing him he's
getting really nervous right really
exasperated he wants to get out of there
and that he's moving out of the room he
trips all of the pain falls on him and
everyone laughs at him even more and
like the scene gets all the more
dramatic and it's way worse for the
character thus the story moves forward
right now they are at the lowest point
because everyone saw this everyone is
making fun of them so if you can find a
way to have each sto each scene move the
story forward and also layer them with
different things that could be advanced
in that story then you have a better
scene what are three questions about a
character every screenwriter should ask
when they start a
scene what the character wants what the
character
needs and what the character is
revealing about themselves I think that
all those three things are essential so
what they need can be usually you know
opposed to what they're getting from the
other person and then what they're
revealing about themselves by the way
they're approaching as scene or the
other character or whatever they're
doing right we good scenes reveal more
about your characters in what they say
or what they don't say the way they act
or react you know so I think that those
are three things that you should be
thinking when you're with a scene you
know you're seeing the two characters
and then what makes it even richer is
that the characters oppose each other
right so what one needs is different
than what the other one needs then that
creates conflict and the thing gets more
layered than more interesting and that's
how we continue to move across and
continue to evolve in that sense when
you've given screenwriters notes to cut
out a scene what's their defense usually
what do they say well this is really
funny or I like when she did this what
do they usually say as a resistance to
well the kill your darling I think is
where that comes from sometimes the
scene is great but it's just not
advancing the story and that happens a
lot with flashbacks where I'm like you
don't need all of this just let the
characters reveal that little by little
and a lot of the times is that
attachment of the kill your darling the
scene is good you know but you don't
need that and my argument there is give
your audience more credit sometimes a
lot of the writers thinks oh but I need
to set this up and I explain no your
audience is smarter than that you don't
need to show them all of those
flashbacks just keep little titbits here
and there PL some things and they will
put the pieces together and that makes
audiences connect more I hate when I'm
watching something and I'm being like
hammered on the head you know oh this is
what happen this is what happened I like
to put the pieces together because that
makes me engage with it more if I'm
constantly being told all of the
different things then I'm on my phone
you know or watching something else but
if I I'm being given little Clues then
I'm more engaged and I'm trying to put
the pieces together I think that happens
a lot with shows like stranger things
which do things so beautifully they're
always giving you little things that
then by the end you put together uh no
spoilers that I'm going to give but
season 4 did that brilliantly with a big
reveal at the end that where where we
were seeing the antagonist of the season
in a way but then when we connect all
things that happen towards the end we
realize oh my God all through the season
they were teasing this big
reveal and I never knew knew that I had
to put it together but I was all the
more engaged and then when I suddenly
started putting it together right before
the actual reveal happened I felt so
smart and I was like this is good
television you know when you're making
me sort of work a little bit but in a
way that keeps me more engaged how can a
screenwriter ruin a
scene I think that they can ruin a scene
when they don't have a purpose for the
scene being there or when they're just
giving you something just to be
expository I think that those are the
main things I would say so either the
scene just doesn't need to be there and
you need to cut it and that's really a
ruin scene or you're just giving me so
much
Exposition that I'm bored right away uh
Exposition is really hard and I get it
there's a lot of stories where you need
to get some points across and you need
your audience to understand that but
what you need to do then is find an
organic way to deliver all of that
Exposition so for example a fish out of
water right so you have the new person
coming into the office so it makes sense
that you're explaining some of the
Dynamics instead if you're just not
having that and you're explaining who
does who in the office that makes no
sense that's just Exposition for the
audience right so you need to find
organic ways of delivering that uh that
also for example connects when you're
having a scene between a husband and
wife and they're overe explaining things
that the other would obviously not know
about each other but you just want to
deliver exposition to your audience that
kills a scene in my opinion because it
just sounds so unnatural of course you
know the backstory the husband and the
wife know how they met you know they
don't need to be explaining remember
when we were doing this and remember
when you we were doing this yes of
course we were both there and we both
know then again if you're trying to
explain it in a different way that's
more interesting like the kid wants to
know the story of how Mom and Dad met
and you need to share that because that
will be important later down in the
story then that's an organic way of them
sharing that story right not just
repeating what they both obviously know
about unless they're like fighting over
the memories right that would be another
way of getting over Exposition and
making that seem better if the husband
remembers it one way and the wife
remembers it a different way then that
makes the story more interesting if they
both remember the same thing and they're
read telling the story then that's just
boring so instead of saying like yeah we
met at this Bakery we were both ordering
TI massu and he took my order by
accident and we were like wait a minute
I think that's my back it would just be
like somebody would say a word like
tiasu or whatever and they both start
yeah right so because they both know
what that means they both know the story
so yeah and and that makes the
characters richer in that sense and that
come goes back to the BIOS that you
wrote for the characters maybe you wrote
the way they met right so you know that
these characters if they say the way the
word tiu they both light up because
they're remembering something about each
other and their story together and then
you don't you need to give again the
audience more credit they will put the
pieces together if you just know they
know that oh that word brings them back
to a happy time you know you don't need
to give as the whole story
just kind of putting some details there
and we'll fill in the blanks sure or it
could also be a it could be maybe one of
them had a bad brother that borrowed
money and never paid it back to the
family and so there's a code word that
reminds them of that exactly you know so
then they start fighting yeah so yeah so
it can work both ways so we don't have
to say this is what this is exactly just
find a way to deliver that Exposition in
a way that's interesting for the
audience to watch and not that they're
watching that scene just to being
hammered over the head like oh I need to
know all of this information for
something else that's just not
entertaining